[Music]
the batman brings audiences a new
terrifying version of the riddler to the
screen while also offering new twists on
an old favorite like the penguin and
catwoman but which characters should
show up for the sequel watch to the end
of the video to see if your pick made
the list
bruce wayne's side job is a costumed
vigilante doesn't leave him with much
time to run the massive empire that his
wayne enterprises instead lucius fox is
often depicted handling these duties as
ceo of the company in the batman mythos
lucius fox is one of the few people that
knows batman's secret identity as bruce
wayne knowledge he puts to good use by
helping batman stay equipped with the
latest and most efficient technology
many of the gadgets and hardware that
batman employs in the field are sourced
by lucius fox the character received his
live-action debut in christopher nolan's
trilogy of batman films in which he was
portrayed by the legendary morgan
freeman in the batman it's clear that
bruce has his operation figured out
without fox but he's still rather young
and can certainly use allies in his
crusade much of his hardware while
effective could use upgrades or
replacements introducing lucius fox
would narratively solve that issue as
bruce advances in his career as the dark
knight
batman has enjoyed an enduring and
ever-expanding mythos over the length of
his career since making his debut in
1939 with the writers and illustrators
of dc comics continually expanding the
character's crew of heroes and villains
while the joker riddler penguin and
twoface are some of batman's most
popular adversaries forging a new path
forward for the dark knight might
require bringing some prominent yet
previously unused characters into the
live-action arena the court of owls is a
more recent addition to the list
courtesy of writer scott snyder and
artist greg coppolo the shadowy
illuminati-like group made its debut in
september of 2011 with the first issue
of batman to hit the shells after dc's
new 52 rebrand was launched the court
sways the future of gotham through its
assassins the talons the most formidable
of which is william cobb immortal due to
the use of a mysterious substance
supplied by the courts called electrum
william tests batman's metal and even
enlightens him revealing a sinister
history behind the city he's sworn to
protect at one point william is even
revealed to be dick grayson's
great-grandfather
two-face is one of batman's most classic
foes obsessed with the number two
because of his scarred face and
fractured identity as far as he's
concerned it's often best to let the
universe decide the answers to life or
death questions with a simple 50 50
chance at the flip of a coin in the
comics cartoons and in the movies he was
once harvey dent a district attorney and
an ally to all that was good and justin
gotham after the mob disfigured him his
psyche shattered his dark side took root
and became one of the city's most feared
gangsters two faces appeared in multiple
live-action films he was portrayed by
tommy lee jones and batman forever with
a much campier portrayal of a deeply
twisted individual pre-two-face era
harvey dent even made an appearance in
1989's batman played by billy d williams
the dark knight entwined dense destiny
with that of the jokers in 2008. his
downfall and rebirth as two-face were
all part of the joker's anarchist plot
to tear the city down
all along two faces never had the
opportunity to reign supreme as the sole
bad guy in his own live-action batman
film if matt reeves took control of his
story there's no telling what madness
this villain could cook up on screen if
the powers that be decided to continue
the noir style theme for the second
adventure of patterson's batman
professor pig would have a darkly
sinister appeal the character was
created by writer grant morrison and
officially became a member of batman's
rogues gallery in 2009's batman and
robin number one professor pig is a mad
scientist with schizophrenia who wears a
horrific pig mask in his madness he
captures victims who he mutilates in the
name of perfection they are transformed
into brainwashed minions known as
dolotrons while he is a conniving
mastermind he transcends standard
criminality in pursuit of his bloody
twisted vision of society professor pig
has no superpowers only his creepy
appearance and skill with overpowering
the mind and forcing his disfigured
victims to do his bidding the
character's high functioning leatherface
vibes may be a bit much for the pg-13
crowd though
jurvis tech is yet another mad scientist
one who recreates himself in the image
of the mad hatter from alice in
wonderland he even associates with two
rotund thugs known as tweedledee and
tweedle dumb tech has developed
technology that allows him to control
people's minds through manipulation of
brainwaves and a fictional level of
neuroscience we couldn't possibly
comprehend he often places hats or cards
with tiny devices on the heads of his
victims in order to take control mad
hatter is actually a creation of one of
batman's co-creators bill finger he's
even made live action appearances on the
small screen from time to time including
an appearance in the 1960s batman series
and fox's pre-batman gotham series
despite his lengthy history he's not one
of the more well-known figures in
batman's coterie of supervillains he
could easily put pattinson's batman to
the test although his sci-fi technology
may be too fantastical for this grounded
take on the character
while robin played a key role in the
1960s batman series his quirky attitude
and catchphrases only served to add to
the comedic campiness of the show joel
schumacher added the sidekick into his
take on the dark knight in batman
forever but schumacher's batman films
doubled down on the 60s style cam holy
rested metal batman huh
you're ground it's all metal it's full
of holes you know
holy oh a more grounded take on the
character of robin and how he'd work
with batman in a more real world setting
would be a fascinating narrative to dig
into the idea of batman putting a young
kid on the front lines against hardened
criminals is already a difficult pill to
swallow with the exception of a small
reference robin was a character
christopher nolan basically ignored in
his gritty dark knight trilogy matt
reeves could potentially crack the code
and deliver a robin that's believable as
a crime fighter and engaging to watch on
screen
one of the more fantastical characters
in the batman mythos clayface might find
it hard to make a home in matt reeve's
more realistic take on batman however
like bane and the dark knight rises he
doesn't have to exactly fit the mold of
his comic book counterpart clayface is a
super villain dreamed up by original
batman creators bill finger and bob kane
there have been multiple versions of the
characters but the original is basil
carlow an actor who prides himself in
his craft in his most recent origin
update he uses a chemical makeup that
ultimately transforms him into clayface
a giant clay monster that can shapeshift
into anything he's a fascinating villain
that really gained notoriety in batman
the animated series
bringing the character into the live
action realm would be difficult and
require a lot of special effects but
it'd be a fresh move for the latest
batman on the big screen
batman has a reputation as a lone wolf
but he has no shortage of allies with
catwoman and batman going their separate
ways in the final moments of the batman
there's a void left behind aside from
robin batman works closely with police
commissioner jim gordon in the comics
and also jim's daughter barbara who
eventually becomes batgirl before being
infamously shot in the spine and
paralyzed by the joker in the killing
joke after her injury she begins
operating as technical support for
batman under the alias oracle with the
dc comics refreshed in 2011 however the
character received a surgical procedure
that restored her ability to walk and
she was batgirl once again batgirl is
already getting her own film in the dc
eu with actor leslie gray standing the
cape and cowl it's likely then that
warner brothers will want to avoid mass
confusion by also introducing batgirl
into the world of the batman however
that doesn't mean we can't see barbara
gordon enter the picture and potentially
play the role of oracle for pattinson's
batman
for most of his existence mr freeze was
a pretty forgettable batman villain that
is until a heart-rending episode of
batman the animated series titled heart
of ice totally overhauled him into a
tragic figure gone was the cheesy
obsession with ice that made him a bit
of a joke instead victor freeze was
given a tragic backstory and a motive
for his villainous ambitions his wife
was dying in an effort to find a cure
for her condition he cryogenically froze
her but a lab accident left him
imprisoned in his cold suit he developed
weaponry to match his icy condition and
typically only engaged in criminal
behavior in an effort to further the
research to save his wife arnold
schwarzenegger played the character in
1997's batman and robin but it left much
to be desired reducing mr freeze to a
collection of puns
alright everyone
the world of pattinson's batman could be
the exact setting needed to offer the
character the emotional depth he
deserves besides sympathetic villains
are some of the most interesting
characters to follow
the brutal mercenary and assassin slade
wilson is a fan favorite whose most
famous story lines involve contracts he
takes to kill major superheroes of
course he's tangled with batman on a
number of occasions video game fans even
had the opportunity to take control of
batman and fight deathstroke in batman
arkham origins in the game the
villainous mob boss black mask puts a
bounty on batman's head and deathstroke
aims to collect he's made a few minor
appearances in the dc eu played by joe
manganello though who knows if that
version will ever return making batman a
target in the batman sequel could amp up
the narrative's intensity as the dark
knight attempts to keep his secret
identity a secret a narrative similar to
arkham origins could be adopted as well
with deathstroke as one of multiple
assassins seeking a payday whatever the
case deathstroke would be an intriguing
addition to the world of patton since
batman
there's more to bruce wayne than a
lonely life avenging his deceased
parents even bruce had friends as a
child including a kid named tommy elliot
tommy's father was abusive and
unfortunately his mother only enabled
his father's behavior tommy became
filled with so much hate for his parents
that he attempted to kill them by
cutting the brakes on their car he
succeeded in killing his father but
bruce's own father saved tommy's mother
enraged tommy grew up resenting bruce
and his family as an adult he adopted
the identity of hush and began a
secretive campaign against bruce during
the day he was a successful and
brilliant neurosurgeon as well as a
plastic surgeon at one point he replaces
his own face with one that looks just
like bruce wayne's so he can destroy
bruce's legacy as hush he covers his
face with bandages he would make a great
addition to the live-action mythos of
the batman after all the riddler's
documentation of gotham's legacy of
corruption did highlight edward elliot
confirming that the elliott family is
very much involved in this version of
gotham
just as his name would suggest killer
croc has the appearance and likeness of
a vicious humanoid crocodile because of
the mutation that wayland jones was born
with he's been cast out of society this
has driven him to lead a life of hatred
and cruelty toward others in his own
madness he often comes to blows with
batman during his criminal endeavors
croc eventually became a well-known
gangster frequently inflicting his
unique brand of violence on others
because of his condition and subsequent
treatment he leans into his perceived
monstrosity by mauling and sometimes
eating his foes while killer croc might
be a bit of a stretch for the world matt
reeves has created there's no telling
what sort of new character arc the
tortured waylon jones could have on
camera of course we've already seen one
iteration of the character in suicide
squad killer croc only acted his muscle
and had no real character depth or
growth in that film i could all change
with a sequel to the batman maybe batman
could dress up as him when batman came
nosing around he was getting closer
closer and
i threw a rock at him
ever since 2008's the dark knight fans
have been itching to see batman and the
joker go toe-to-toe again on the big
screen yes jared leto played the joker
in suicide squad and zack snyder's
justice league and joaquin phoenix
landed the role in a solo film all about
the clown prince of crime's origins even
winning an oscar for his trouble but
neither one of those jokers directly
squared off with batman in a full movie
the joker is perhaps batman's most
popular foe and for good reason there
are many ways to interpret the character
and he's often highly unpredictable the
mystery behind what fuels his madness
naturally creates intrigue truly
establishing the character in the world
of the batman would take guts as it'll
unavoidably draw comparisons to ledger's
incredible dark knight performance
however it's time that fancy batman
truly confronts his greatest foe on
screen again
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the batman are coming soon subscribe to
our youtube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]